[Music]  more job opportunities across the valley  olive garden  opening a brand new location on las  vegas boulevard looking to fill  servers line cooks bartender positions  there is a job fair next week on june  28th as well as june 29th from 10 in the  morning until four in the afternoon  it will be held at the olive garden near  flamingo and maryland parkway  you are asked to bring two forms of id  to this  coming up tomorrow arizona charlie's  will have an on the spot hiring event at  the decatur location from 10 a.m to 2  p.m 1 000  signing bonuses being offered bus passes  as well up for grabs  we've got a full list of companies who  are hiring right now with links to apply  it's all on our website  eightnewsnow.com just click the job  board tab